[Music]  yes a little no I danced a little bit in  this movie it's fun are you a good  dancer I'm a great dancer you know  wouldn't you turn to I love to dance  I love the dance I'll dance in a minute  right now but I'm the same way people  look at me and they think he can't move  and then I start to do stuff on the  floor people he's maybe had a good thing  going right there for a second I tried  you and I really connected in a way  [Applause]  [Applause]  I got tired out really quickly you guys  should try to get over there on the  shiny floor  [Applause]  a toy I tore I tore everything in here  and in here  and then back here I tore stuff I don't  even have I would you get with time to  dance with me man it was a mistake  there's a terrible mistake  [Applause]